full of energy and political will to
fight in upcoming elections rahan Ze was
no stranger to the authorities the
30-year-old had been detained during a
Crackdown of members of the Pakistan
tarika party or PTI he continued to
campaign and said he wasn't afraid of
death he was from bajur that borders
Afghanistan and is a key operating
ground for the Pakistani Taliban Al
jazer spoke with him last year we spent
almostly 20 years almostly 30 years
under war and Terror that is not
acceptable furthermore because we we
youth want uh jobs we want education
almostly very alarming figure of the
education literacy rate just just 20% of
the male literacy and just 5% of women
literacy rate we already living in the
darkness instead of providing education
and and basic facility they provide us
buming 6 months after that interview he
was gunned down in broad daylight by
unknown
assassins his father spoke at his
funeral
prayer what was my son's crime to fight
for a cause for his
people his funeral was attended by
hundreds of people shocked and
[Applause]
angry they took their anger out on
Pakistan's military staging protests and
voicing their dissent the military
establishment has increasingly been
blamed for a Crackdown on Khan's party
his video is now gaining even more
traction online after his
death every child will become a leader
in bajour you are the leaders don't call
yourself political workers you are
leaders call yourself leaders
authorities have told Al jaaz they're
investigating the killing but no arrests
have been made Imran Khan Still Remains
one of the most popular politicians in
the country despite being in jail his
party members have borne the brunt of
the Crackdown some have been barred from
standing others have seen their family
members targeted the symbol of a cricket
batch removed from the ballot paper
their posters and campaign materials
torn down from the streets 120 million
people are eligible to vote in this
election making Pakistan one of the
largest democracies in the world but
what has happened in the runup is
Raising questions about how fair they
will be assal Al jazer laor
Pakistan make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer